resuelven 4 es igual al logaritmo en
base b de 81 para b y bueno a mí lo que
se me ocurre es que podemos ver esta
misma ecuación en su forma exponencial
las formas pueden ser resolverla de una
manera mucho más sencilla así que vamos
a pasar del lenguaje de logaritmos al
lenguaje de la función exponencial ibn b
es la base del logaritmo por lo tanto va
a ser la base de mi función exponencial
así que vamos a escribir esto de la
misma manera pero de una manera
equivalente y me queda que ven elevado a
qué potencia pues elevado a la potencia
4 tiene que ser igual a 81 recuerda que
eso es justo lo que nos dice el
logaritmo logaritmo en base b de 81 es
igual a 4 quiere decir que b elevado a
la cuarta potencia es igual a 81 o ve a
qué potencia me de 81 pues eso es igual
a 4 pero lo que queremos es resolver
para ver por lo tanto necesitamos saber
el valor de b pero por suerte 81 si te
das cuenta es un cuadrado perfecto 81 lo
podemos escribir la siguiente manera 81
es lo mismo que 9 por 99 por una vez 81
o dicho de otra manera
81 y para nuestra buena suerte 9 también
es un cuadrado perfecto 9 es lo mismo
que 3 por 3 aquí me quedaría 3 por 3 que
me da es de 9 y después aquí tengo otro
9 por lo tanto tengo que multiplicar por
3 y después otra vez por 3 es 3 x 3 x 3
por 3 o lo que es lo mismo 9 por 9 lo
que es lo mismo 81 pero 3 por 3 x 3 por
3 es lo mismo que tres a la cuarta qué
buena suerte porque entonces se nos está
diciendo que 3 elevado a la cuarta es lo
mismo que 81 o dejan poner un color más
delgado 3 elevado a la cuarta es igual a
81 entonces de aquí tengo b elevado a la
cuartos 81 y yo sé que 13 elevada a la
cuarta es 81 pues por lo tanto no me
queda de otra vez tiene que ser igual a
3 y ya con esto encontré la solución de
esta ecuación logarítmica 3 elevado a la
cuarta es igual a 81 o puedo decir que
el hogar y no en base 3 de 81 es decir a
qué potencia tengo que elevar a 3 para
que me dé 81 ya sé que la respuesta de
esto es igual a 43 elevado a la cuarta
es lo mismo que 81 por lo tanto ya tengo
la solución de esta ecuación lo gary
sin embargo también hay otra forma de
verlo me gustaría decirlo por aquí si yo
saco raíz cuarta es decir de aquí lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar más bien
elevar todo a la potencia un cuarto voy
a usar potencias en forma de fracción
para que puedan resolver esta ecuación
de otra manera me queda b elevado a la 4
elevado a un cuarto es igual a 81
elevado en un cuarto pero b elevado a la
4 elevado al un cuarto las potencias se
multiplican y 4 por un cuarto eso mismo
que cuatro cuartos que es lo mismo que a
uno es decir esto es b y por el otro
lado tengo 81 elevado a un cuarto pero
recuerda que el elevado de un cuarto es
exactamente lo mismo que sacar raíz
cuarta y la raíz cuarta por lo que
acabamos de ver de 81 es igual a 3
porque 3 cuando lo multiplicó por si
mismo cuatro veces me da 81 que es justo
lo mismo que me dice la raíz cuarta por
lo tanto ya de aquí obtendría que vale 3
y entonces ya otra vez tengo el mismo
resultado de la ecuación logarítmica
llegaría a lo mismo y está perfecto sin
embargo no quiero que te hagas bolas con
todo esto si me entendiste el primer
procedimiento está perfecto y no
hablemos de raíces cuartas
ni de potencias con fracciones perfecto
las respuestas 3 porque si 3 la elevamos
a la potencia 4 obtengo 81 y ya con esto
hemos acabado